ya hemos estado hablando un montón de
tiempo acerca de las proteínas acerca de
la enorme variedad de cosas que hacen en
los sistemas biológicos desde actuar
como hormonas o anticuerpos hasta
proveer estructuras en las células o ser
mecanismos de señalización y toda una
serie de cosas y ahora su habilidad para
hacer todo ese tipo de cosas en los
sistemas vivos proviene es un producto
de su estructura así es que de lo que
vamos a hablar en este vídeo es de la
estructura de las proteínas y para poder
realmente apreciar la estructura de las
proteínas vamos a observar a una
molécula de hemoglobina lo que hay por
aquí tenemos una molécula de hemoglobina
y las moléculas de hemoglobina están
compuestas por cuatro cadenas poli
peptídicas dos de ellas tienen 141
aminoácidos y las otras dos tienen 146
aminoácidos así es que en total tienen
574 aminoácidos 574 aminoácidos pero
como podemos ver esos aminoácidos no
están en alguna configuración aleatoria
están organizados en cierta
configuración que es muy buena para
hacer lo que hace la hemoglobina lo cual
es transportar oxígeno la hemoglobina es
muy buena transportando oxígeno dentro
de las células rojas y bueno así como
tenemos las proteínas de la hemoglobina
hay muchísimos muchísimos muchísimos
otros tipos de proteínas que hacen un
montón de otro tipo de cosas pero
cómo le hacen para obtener su estructura
y bueno una forma de pensar en todo esto
es ver que hay diferentes niveles de
estructura y el primer nivel de la
estructura le podemos llamar estructura
primaria y esta es simplemente el orden
de los aminoácidos que componen a esta
proteína
cuando hablamos acerca del paso de la
traducción que tenemos por ahí algún rn
mensajero a rn m que llega a un ribosoma
y luego hay por ahí algunos a rn de
transferencia arnette que se dedican a
traer aminoácidos y juntarlos y se
empiezan a enlazar entre ellos justo ahí
es donde se está formando la estructura
primaria y justo el adn o bueno la
información en el adn lo que está
programando es esto de aquí aunque ya
está programando en qué orden se van a
enlazar los aminoácidos
así es que la estructura primaria es
simplemente el orden en el que se
encuentran los aminoácidos el orden de
los aminoácidos la estructura primaria
es simplemente el orden es simplemente
como formamos a nuestro polipéptido a
partir de los aminoácidos pero también
nos podemos preguntar cómo le hace el
poli péptido para doblarse de todas
estas formas y poder hacer todo ese tipo
de cosas que necesita hacer bueno pues
en la estructura secundaria la
estructura secundaria y la estructura
secundaria se debe a las interacciones
que hay en el esqueleto proteico y tengo
unos cuantos ejemplos de eso por aquí
como podemos ver por aquí tenemos una
cadena poli peptídica tenemos un montón
de aminoácidos que están enlazados con
estos enlaces peptídicos esto de aquí es
un enlace peptídicos
y por aquí también tenemos otro enlace
peptídicos entre el carbono del grupo
carbon hilo y el nitrógeno y buscamos
otro carbono del grupo carbón y lo
enlazado con un nitrógeno y tenemos otro
enlace peptídicos y fácilmente nos
podemos imaginar que esta cadena poli
peptídica baja por aquí pero luego
vuelve a subir y vuelve a bajar pero por
aquí estamos viendo que cuando vuelve a
bajar tiene el mismo sentido
aquí tenemos nitrógeno y luego el
carbono del grupo carbón y lo luego el
enlace peptídicos y otra vez nitrógeno
carbono del grupo carbón hilo y enlace
pep típico y lo que estamos viendo por
aquí es que el esqueleto del polipéptido
está interactuando incluso decidí no
dibujar las cadenas laterales y poner
simplemente una r por aquí para cada una
de las distintas cadenas laterales para
hacer más énfasis en cómo interactúa el
esqueleto del polipéptido
ejemplo aquí tenemos este nitrógeno que
es mucho más electro negativo que este
hidrógeno por lo cual el nitrógeno está
abrazando los electrones de este enlace
y el hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva por otro lado tenemos aquí a
este oxígeno que es más electro negativo
que el carbono y por lo tanto está
abrazando a los electrones de este
carbono y tiene una carga parcial
negativa y entonces este hidrógeno y
este oxígeno se van a sentir atraídos y
se va a formar un puente de hidrógeno
ok este es uno de esos famosísimos
puentes de hidrógeno y lo mismo está
sucediendo por aquí y también lo mismo
está sucediendo por acá y entonces estas
dos cadenas pueden formar como una hoja
o una lámina y bueno de hecho se les
llama así se les llama hoja plegada beta
o bueno también algunas veces se le
llama lámina beta
ahora por aquí también construyó una
hoja plegada de eta pero tal vez puedas
encontrar fácilmente la diferencia entre
estas dos por aquí y vamos del nitrógeno
al carbono alfa
este es el carbono alfa al carbono del
grupo carbon hilo y luego otra vez al
nitrógeno aunque hay del nitrógeno al
carbono alfa este es otro carbono alfa
al carbono del grupo carbon hilo y otra
vez al nitrógeno y de este lado también
estábamos viendo en la misma dirección
empezábamos en nitrógeno carbono
alfa carbono del grupo carbón y lo
nitrógeno y luego otra vez carbono alfa
carbono del grupo carbon hilo y
nitrógeno así es que esta es una hoja
plegada beta paralela estos dos
esqueletos que están interactuando están
yendo en la misma dirección
así es que diríamos que esta hoja
plegada beta es paralela que es una hoja
plegada beta paralela
mientras que en esta otra de aquí ok
podemos ver que los esqueletos son
paralelos pero podemos ver por aquí que
estamos yendo del nitrógeno al carbono
alfa al carbono del grupo carbón y lo
nitrógeno carbono alfa carbono del grupo
carbón y lo nitrógeno esto es lo que
sucede del lado izquierdo pero del lado
derecho estamos viendo nitrógeno carbono
del grupo carbón y lo carbono alfa
nitrógeno carbono del grupo carbón y lo
carbono alfa nitrógeno y estamos yendo
en la dirección opuesta de hecho hasta
lo dibujé de cabeza lo que hay bueno en
realidad nada más tome este esqueleto y
lo volteé y lo pegue por acá y por eso
están las letras de cabeza no creo pero
seguimos teniendo estos puentes de
hidrógeno estos puentes de hidrógeno
entre el hidrógeno que tiene una carga
parcial positiva porque el nitrógeno es
más electro negativo y este oxígeno que
tiene una carga parcial negativa que hay
por aquí seguimos teniendo estos puentes
de hidrógeno
y también tenemos que los esqueletos son
paralelos pero estamos yendo en
direcciones opuestas
así es que diríamos que estas son hojas
plegadas beta anti paralelas anti
paralelas hoja plegada beta anti
paralela o también conocida como lámina
beta anti paralela así es que esta es
otra forma de estructura secundaria y
luego por aquí tenemos esta cosa y
podemos ver que este esqueleto tiene una
forma de hélice y aquí tenemos puentes
de hidrógeno entre los distintos niveles
de la hélice por aquí tenemos este
oxígeno que tiene una carga parcial
negativa y un hidrógeno que tiene una
carga parcial positiva y se forma un
puente de hidrógeno entre estos dos y
por acá también se forma un puente de
hidrógeno y esto es lo que le da la
estructura de hélice
esta le llamamos hélice alfa entonces
estas interacciones entre los esqueletos
de los polis péptidos vamos para arriba
y esas interacciones entre los
esqueletos de los polis péptidos es lo
que forma la estructura secundaria pero
todavía no terminemos porque como te
puedes imaginar estas cadenas laterales
también nos dicen algo acerca de la
estructura de la proteína
algunas de estas cadenas laterales
pueden ser hidrofóbicas y entonces
pueden tratar de huir del exterior y
pueden tratar de irse hacia adentro de
la molécula o también puede ser que
algunas de estas cadenas laterales
formen puentes de hidrógeno entre sí y
entonces están interactuando de cierta
forma también podemos tener cadenas
laterales que formen enlaces de sulfuro
o incluso enlaces covalentes con algunas
otras cadenas laterales y vamos a ver
esto con mucho más detalle pronto en
algún otro vídeo pero por el momento en
este vídeo el tercer nivel
estructura es la estructura terciaria y
la estructura terciaria se debe a las
interacciones entre las cadenas
laterales se debe a las interacciones
entre cadenas laterales nos podemos
imaginar que tenemos por aquí nuestra
proteína
y tal vez tengo un montón de cadenas
laterales hidrofóbicas por aquí ya todas
les estoy llamando r pero supongamos que
son diferentes cadenas hidrofóbicas y
que por ejemplo el agua está por aquí
afuera y entonces estas cadenas
laterales hidrofóbicas van a tratar de
alejarse del agua y bueno también puede
ser que tengas cadenas laterales que
sean hidrofílicas que sean polares y
esas cadenas laterales tal vez van a
querer estar del lado del agua también
podemos tener una situación en la que
tenemos una cadena r 1 y en algún otro
lugar tengamos una cadena r 2 y que se
forme un puente de hidrógeno entre estas
dos cadenas laterales o tal vez en lugar
de un puente de hidrógeno tienen un
enlace iónico así es que podemos pensar
en un montón de diferentes tipos de
interacciones entre las cadenas
laterales y vamos a ver todo eso a fondo
pero en un vídeo próximamente ahora
cualquier proteína que esté compuesta
únicamente por un solo polipéptidos
va a tener únicamente estructura
primaria secundaria y terciaria sin
embargo si estamos tratando con una
proteína como la hemoglobina que está
formada por más de un poli péptido
entonces vamos a poder hablar de la
estructura cuaternaria estructura
cuaternaria y ésta se trata de cómo se
juntan las distintas cadenas de
polipéptidos para formar moléculas más
complejas y más largas
la estructura cuaternaria la define el
arreglo de varias cadenas poli
peptídicas el arreglo de varias en el
caso de la hemoglobina fueron cuatro
cadenas poli peptídicas cadenas poli
peptídicas bueno espero que esto te haya
dado una muy buena idea de la estructura
de las proteínas que por cierto es toda
un área fascinante lo que hay porque hay
muchísimas permutaciones para construir
distintas
líneas y si las lográramos entender
mejor podríamos pasar mucho más fácil
del adn a la estructura primaria y luego
de la estructura primaria podríamos
entender mucho mejor cómo funcionan las
proteínas qué hacen y cómo arreglarlas y
qué podemos hacer para tal vez
proporcionar algunas proteínas que hagan
algunas otras funciones
así es que esto de la estructura de las
proteínas es todo un tema súper
fascinante es verdaderamente un campo de
estudio increíble